all right welcome to Hannity and
breaking tonight the investigation into
the deep state's abuse of power has now
come full circle
finally Fox News tonight can confirm
Christopher Steele the former mi6 agent
who created the dirty Clinton bought and
paid for Russian dossier was in fact
grilled by federal prosecutors in June
now the interview with Steele reportedly
lasted over 15 hours it was conducted by
lawyers that were working for the DOJ as
Inspector General that's Michael
Horowitz this is one of two reasons that
the IG report is delayed the other being
key witnesses now at the last minute
have finally decided to cooperate this
is going to get very interesting but
make no mistake about it a crucial
development in the IG s investigation
into FISA abuse that would be James
Comey Sally Yates Andrew McCabe and yeah
even Rod Rosenstein should be very
worried tonight we know for a fact that
Steele's dirty dossier bought and paid
for by Hillary Clinton was unverified as
a matter of fact unverifiable full of
salacious lies even Christopher steel
himself previously admitting under oath
he had no idea whether any of the
contents were true or not and we know
the New York Times now suggesting that
that dossier Russian dossier was full of
Russian misinformation from the get-go
to influence the 2016 elections and more
now robert muller and trying to
understand maybe we'll find out next
wednesday why did you and your team have
time for farah violations loan
applications from years gone by taxi
medallions taxes from years gone by how
did you possibly ignore hillary
clinton's bought and paid for russian
lies used to get a warrant to spy on the
Trump campaign the Trump transition and
the Trump presidency and of course we
also know Christopher Steele hated
Donald Trump and he was being paid a ton
of money let's he was being paid by the
Clinton campaign the DNC the FBI and
some oligarch good gig if he can get it
he paid for people pay you for Lies and
so steal spread his BS anti Trump rumors
to anyone and everyone who would listen
including high-level officials in the
FBI the DOJ Obama's State Department the
Intel community and we now know multiple
media outlets even after he was fired
for lying and leaking by the FBI while
he was still using Bruce or to funnel
more lies this time to Muller and his
team of witch hunters by the way did
Muller use any of this information great
question for next Wednesday now because
the Steel's rampant bias conflicts of
interest and blatant inaccuracies in his
so-called research while now multiple
serious red flags were raised by
officials at the FBI the State
Department and many many others that
didn't seem to matter to James Comey the
super patriot he used this phony Russian
dossier filled with these lies as the
basis for the FISA warrant application
that's right to spy on the Trump
campaign he's for that the evidence was
true and accurate at the top of that I
am told at the top of the FISA
application says verified but we know it
was nothing but anyway joining us now
tonight with so much more on Steele's
time in the hot seat our own Catherine
Herridge Catherine one thing that stands
out is if he testified 15 hours we know
in an interrogatory under oath under the
threat of perjury he went on the record
saying no no he didn't know if any of it
was true
well that's right Charlene good evening
based on our reporting the former
British spy Christopher Steele was
concerned he would get quote thrown
under the bus in the inspector general's
report and the appointment of US
Attorney John Durham to investigate the
origins of the Russia probe ramped up
the pressure on Steele to cooperate Fox
News was first to report that a key
witness outside the FBI and Justice
Department had agreed to talk with the
Inspector General Michael e Horowitz at
the 11th hour and that a now appears to
be steel rotors broke new details this
morning of the steel was interviewed in
the UK in June by three lawyers from the
inspector general's office and as we
reported on your show last night
these late-breaking developments
required some witnesses to be
reinterviews
to deconflict their accounts flagging
another potentially significant detail
that Steele was apparently interviewed
twice by investigators working for
Special Counsel Robert Muller in
September 2017 but the nearly 500 page
report
makes no direct reference to the so
called sealed dossier used to secure the
surveillance warrant for Trump campaign
8 the Muller report calls the dossier
instead steel reporting or steel reports
which has the effect of minimizing the
fact that Democrats pay for the
opposition research used by the FBI and
DOJ to secure that surveillance warrant
in October 2016 and then they used it
again to secure multiple renewal Shawn
unbelievable and now we know why the
Inspector General has been delayed
interviewing steel these other people
coming forward as per your report last
night great work as loys
you're in charge in Washington tonight
now it has been said absolute power
corrupts absolutely
now nowhere is this more obvious than
the Russia witch-hunt Bob Muller's Mary
banned Democratic donors they were given
a very broad mandate and platform and
tremendous power to investigate all
things Donald Trump and Russian
interference and while they found no
collusion no conspiracy no chargeable
obstruction they did manage to wreck the
lives of multiple people that were
associated with the president of course
with strong-arm tactics that should make
every single American concerned if you
care about constitutional and civil
liberties by the way not even war hero
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn 33
years of service he was not spared
either the combat vet fell victim to
what was a perjury trout McCabe called
me bragging about it he and member of
his members of his family were
threatened with significant prison time
his screws were turned in the hopes that
he'd sing or compose as judge Ellis once
said and of course in the process
mounting legal bills wrecked his family
finances he had to sell his house he
ultimately agreed to plea guilty to
lying to the FBI and the FBI didn't
think he lied he did it to save his
family and his son in particular but
tonight thanks to investigative reporter
Sarah Carter we are learning some
damning new information about Flynn's
plea deal and according to our brand-new
legal counsel the ever so powerful smart
Sidney Powell prosecutors actually
wanted Flynn to lie under oath against
his former business partner in
case surrounding again a fara violation
a recent defense filing States quote the
prosecutors have been adamant that mr.
Flynn testified that he authorized the
filing of the fara form knowing and
intending that it contained false
statements mr. Flynn cannot give that
testimony because it's not true
according to Sara Carter's reporting
because Flynn is refusing to give the
testimony they are demanding that he
says it's not true federal prosecutors
are now planning to portray Flynn as a
co-conspirator in the case